just breaking news uh ian rappaport is
joining us in hour three there'll be
lots to talk about with him
is uh tweeting out what mike mccarthy
just said
in dallas told reporters that andy
dalton participated in a quarterback
meeting today but won't practice
it appears based on where he is in the
protocol that dalton is unlikely to play
this sunday ben dinucci
who is the seventh-round draft choice of
the cowboys this year out of james
madison university has received
all the first team reps and that is how
we welcome in the head coach of the
philadelphia
eagles in his fifth campaign there our
friend of the program doug peterson how
are you coach
rich i'm doing well today thank you you
bet thank you for joining i appreciate
that did i just break you a little bit
of news to you right there about
who your defense might be facing on
sunday
yeah just a little bit you know and it's
i tell you this
it's it we understandably because
you know obviously you go into the
concussion protocol and it takes some
time
um you know to be cleared from that
we've had a couple guys this season that
have done that and and you know they
usually don't get cleared till friday or
saturday and they're
they're but they participate you know it
was obviously good that's a positive in
the right direction but
you know we still have to plan as if uh
you know uh
for you know uh denucci to play and and
then also
also be prepared if something changes
and andy plays as well
so i'm gonna ask you a question i've
never asked you and i'm sure you've
rarely been asked but
because we are in the pandemic season
where there was no preseason action
uh have you pulled james madison tape
in philadelphia
we've had to we've had to this week uh
and go back and
pull out our pull out our tape pull out
our notes you know
um as as we've evaluated quarterbacks in
the past you know especially offensively
and just kind of get a get a feel for
for him and what he can do and
and uh it is hard when you don't have
the pre-season games to go back and
watch
you know and to see these guys it's a
it's uh it's
tough for for any any team but obviously
in this case because it is a quarterback
position
well and and obviously you you know
firsthand that you never
you you you can always expect uh your
backup
uh you you know to play better than many
people would think
um you know that firsthand but obviously
nick foles had had more
run and you've had more run yourself in
that position than dinucci is going to
have going into this game what what can
you
expect from the opposition quarterback
doug well i think i think yeah i think
number one you gotta you gotta expect
the unexpected um which is
you know um you know any kind of gadget
play or
some sort of trick play things things of
those those natures where they they
tried to create plays and help the
quarterback
i i also believe that you know uh you
you probably get a constant dose of
you know zeke elliott too you know um
in this football game and be prepared
obviously for that because we know that
they have a strong running game and he's
a powerful back and that also can help
um
you know young quarterbacks in this
league and then quite frankly you've
we've all seen it where a young
quarterback comes in
and and can play lights out you know he
gets hot he gets streaky he's got
weapons on offense with the you know the
three receivers the running back that
they have so
you know it's sort of the unexpected um
you know until you until you get into
the game but
uh we have to be prepared for all of it
doug peterson here on the rich eisen
show
um the dallas cowboys coming with a
banged up offensive line but
you uh as the kids would say maybe hold
my beer right
i mean you've got you've got your own
issues on that front
if you don't mind i'd love to run
through um some of the issues that you
do have with with some injured players
uh jason peters you are expecting back
however on sunday correct
yeah he practiced yesterday um he looked
good
you know we'll see where he's at today
but optimistic and hopeful that uh he
can
he can make it back and and uh and play
play sunday yeah for sure okay and lane
johnson seems to be
you know getting in there and then
running off the field it's just been so
inconsistent on trying to keep him
healthy what's his scoop
well he he had an injury uh coming out
of
the kind of the last week of you know
so-called training camp where where we
kind of arrested him a little bit
so he was recovering from that and then
he had a couple other injuries that kind
of you know
on top of the one he had coming out of
camp and he's battled through some stuff
and and uh you know he he came out of
the game last week and went back in and
eventually came out for
good but he's another one that's a tough
kid and and uh
you know we expect him to to be in there
this uh this sunday as well
okay what about your running back mile
sanders i'm sorry to do this
but i mean but you have so many name
players
um and so many key members of your
offense that have been
banged up what about miles sanders coach
miles is getting closer um you know we
do have the bye week
uh you know lurking next week and we
just want to be careful with him but
he's he's
he's more of a of a day-to-day he's
improving um
this week and and we'll see where he's
at you know
tomorrow and saturday before there's a
decision made with him
i just don't want to put him back out
there if if he's
you know one if he's hesitant or he's
not a hundred percent you know
especially at the running back position
and and
especially what he does for us in our
offense you know being a third down back
and
i want to be careful for him with him
because we have a lot of a lot of
football remaining
you know at the end of the season so
he's one that uh we just got to see here
towards the end of the week how uh how
he responds and then you've got a hertz
on the good side
jalen who i adore uh that guy's a winner
he's a gamer he's as he said when he
when i had him on
leading the draft he said he wants to be
a dog for a team that gets him and that
he will be
a leader um where where is he in your
playbook here
do you think you might use him a little
bit more as you're you're searching for
points
um on a week and week out basis
well that's that's just the thing with
jalen is is you know
one i want to i want to make sure that
that you know we
we coach him and train him and bring him
up in our system as a quarterback and
and not just a not just a guy that you
know we can just put in from
you know from time to time to be a a
gadget guy or whatever we want to make
sure that the reps he's getting are
valuable reps and
and he can make he can make plays for us
and that's his role right now for us but
i'm encouraged by where he is in our
offense you know he
a young player he's learning everything
i mean he's not
he's not going to be where carson is in
year five as far as understanding
everything but
but he has a good understanding of our
offense and and uh could go in and
execute if if need be
but right now his role is is to help us
create some
sort of off-schedule plays and use his
talent and use his uh
athleticism that way and uh he's
embraced that role and he's helped us do
that
here in the last uh you know four or
five weeks or for some who might not be
familiar with the phrase what do you
when you say off schedule
do you mean down distance or you're just
talking about
um what when you say off schedule well
off off schedule can be you know sort of
the unscouted looks things that your
opponent's not going to see on film
you know when they when they're looking
at us when they're game planning for us
yes they're going to see plays that
jaylen is in and executing but for us
it's it's another play that they haven't
seen
so you kind of go off schedule right off
off your normal routine to
to come up with plays that can help you
um you know in the course of a ballgame
doug peterson philadelphia eagles head
coach
getting set to take his team into sunday
night football on nbc against the dallas
cowboys just a big game
because i'm sure you've heard uh the
schedules up uh the the uh divisions up
for grabs i'm sure you've heard that
right
coach you've you've heard that story
i've heard it once or twice i've heard
that once or twice
probably probably since about week one i
mean is this the craziest
division you've ever been in uh anywhere
player coach
it is i've i've yeah as a player and or
coach i've never been a part of a
division that's
just quite like this i've never seen it
where
you know i know two teams in particular
are extremely banged up
you know us the cowboys um giants
obviously have
you know some injury situations going on
washington
you know got a few injuries but not not
too bad and i think they're the team
that's kind of improving and looking
looking better i just it's it's a crazy
it's a crazy year
all around um you know from from
the pandemic you know to to social
distancing to
to how we are within our building and
games being either postponed or
rescheduled and then
you know our division the way it is but
you know i think
i think you know for us we just gotta we
just gotta stay the course
trust our process do the things that
that we know uh are to be true and and
help us
help us win it's always been you know
the next man up mentality here and
we've we've obviously had to do that in
the last three four weeks with the
amount of you know injuries but
our guys are excited we're looking
forward to you know to sunday night and
then playing the cowboys and then of
course there's the million dollar
question or in the case of your
quarterback the 100 million dollar
question that carson wentz has looked
off
that he has looked uh unlike the guy
let's just say
who put you in the position of the one
seed for nick foles and you
and the rest of the crew to take it home
a few years ago
where do you evaluate your quarterback
right now
well i think he's i think the first part
of the season
um there were some situations you know
we didn't we haven't had al shawn
jeffrey uh we've had desean jackson
limited
uh and then you know a lot of people
probably don't remember
you know we had marquis goodwin coming
in who opted out this season so we had
three of our top guys
really that were were going to be sort
of mainstays around carson so that that
kind of disrupted us a little bit early
um and then we lose dallas goddard you
know early in the season and now zach
gertz and so there's been a lot of
moving pieces around carson and
i i think carson's done a great job of
keeping everybody together
and executing our offense these last
couple of weeks have been
um really good for him uh personally and
also as a team
you know you know again the thursday
night game
last week and and had a chance to beat
baltimore who i
i think is one of the top top teams in
the league right now playing extremely
well and
so but our quarterback carson is playing
is playing better and
he's learning to play with these young
players which we did at the end of
season last year and
he's really rallied those guys he's uh i
think he's encouraged we're all
encouraged by it
they're they're learning it's it's not
perfect by any means but
um it's something that we can definitely
build a foundation on and um
until we can get these other guys
healthy well in terms of you know his
um his efficiency this year the phrase
that i've heard quite a bit
whether it's from my hall of fame
quarterback to two seats down to my left
on
on nfl game day morning and kurt warner
or just um you know
uh the armchair quarterbacks is the
concept of doing too much that you just
will not give up on a play to the
detriment of
himself and the play and the team and
you obviously know
somebody who has succeeded with that and
farve i mean he might be the poster
he might be the poster guy in the hall
of fame of doing too much
but i mean do you have this conversation
with wence at all
on this front coach we do yeah we
we constantly have the conversation and
i just you know we just want to make
sure that carson understands that he
doesn't have to make every play and and
you know sometimes it's hard to when
when you i think when you struggle as an
offense or
you don't have all your pieces around
you your offensive line is a little
disruptive i mean we don't have isaac
see a model brandon brooks guys like
that that are out there playing
those guys aren't there you feel like as
a quarterback that
you got to put everybody on your
shoulders and you gotta like hey you
know
follow me and and you you really don't
have to do that
you know trust trust the process play
play good ball and that means you know
you can you can rely on your defense i
feel like we got a good defense that you
can rely on too you know in special
teams and play the field position game
and um those are all things i think you
constantly learn
you know uh not only as young players
but uh as quarterbacks in this league
and
but we we have those conversations you
know um
you know each week i think i think you
have to continue to revisit it's not
something you do in training camp and
then
you know you don't talk about it anymore
you got to keep talking about it and
just keep keep educating not only him
but i think i think everybody on on that
topic
and then of course he'll just uncork one
too uh doug and
this to me was uh you know we may look
back on it that that pass to travis
fulghum
uh in san francisco um that
essentially um turned helped turn things
around on the spot for you
and and is it true that those guys had
only repped it once
or had never repped it before can you
walk me through
that moment yeah that that particular
play
um you know travis is more of an alert
um
as not necessarily the he's not like one
or two in the progression it's it's an
alert if we get the coverage we want
he can he can take it and um
we we actually did it one time in
practice but it was actually a broken
play
it was a a situation where um
the play the play broke down carson
moved a little bit to his left and
travis got free up that
up the same side like left sideline the
whole thing in practice and
and got in behind the defender we
executed that in practice so
we get into the game and we call it
again but this time we got the defense
we wanted
and it was just a well executed play by
those two guys and then you're seeing
the i think the comfort level between
carson and travis right now and
travis improving each week as is a lot
of the young guys you know and
um i'm also excited for for jaylen rager
this week that's right he's coming back
into practice okay
you know getting him going again he's
another one that we've missed pretty
much all season so far so
you know i'm excited about that and john
hightower and
you know these guys jj you know our sega
white side i mean these are young guys
that
we're excited about and we just got to
continue to coach them isn't it amazing
how it works
in this world man i mean that your top
receivers technically
are a kid from old dominion that just is
new to your team and uh
uh a converted quarterback from houston
in ward i mean who made one of the best
catches of last year for you
it's just amazing how this league works
huh sometimes
it is it is and you know this league has
all been always been about opportunities
you know
for those guys and and i think about my
career just having an opportunity as an
undrafted free agent that's what it
takes sometimes just getting an
opportunity to get your foot in the door
a team to kind of you know hey
have a little faith a little trust in
you as a player and you go execute and
that's what you're seeing with our guys
you know there's no egos there
they work hard during the week they
practice hard and again it's not it's
not perfect there's still mistakes being
made but
you know i don't mind coaching off of
touchdown passes and uh
completions uh that's always a good
thing to to coach
how often do you talk to homegrown in a
couple minutes i have left with you
do you connect with him at all or just
um i do not really i do
um yeah no i do i do reach out to him
uh he's always been one of the one of
the sort of the mentor coaches for me
obviously played for him and now um you
know being on the other side of the
the playing field being in the coaches
seat especially head coach's seat
i have reached out to him and and you
know picked his brain on certain things
over over the course of my five years
here
do you i mean and uh and re andy did you
uh
speak to him at all about his uh choice
of
of visor um you know he's going shield
he went shield and then i think he went
mask last week i
i don't know i guess it depends on the
weather and the fogging and all of that
sort of stuff
doug it depends yeah it depends you know
i've just gone with the with the actual
mask each week the shield is kind of
cool because it looks like it clips
right onto his
hat you know and it keeps it keeps the
the wind he's got the holes in it and
the whole thing it's sort of aerodynamic
and
i'm a little envious of it because uh it
does look kind of cool well
um the thing i don't know i'd like to i
gotta get one somewhere the thing i
don't understand is he's the king of
covering his mouth with his play sheet
and the mask
can actually do that for you and he's
going clear
when the mask can actually help with the
lip reading
and the health uh and safetyness i don't
under i don't
i'm but look i don't question it i'm
with you
i'm with you that's why i wear the mask
because then they can't read my lips
there you go
very good it's a beautiful thing well
which is also depending on the
on the situation over the last seven
weeks probably also a good thing uh
for for for lip readers
that's absolutely right thanks for the
co uh thanks for the call coach i look
forward to seeing you on
sunday night let's uh let's chat down
the road
all right thanks a lot rich thanks for
having me on you guys doug peterson of
the
two four and one yet first place
philadelphia eagles
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here